قضيه الهجره غير شرعيه كانت في قلب اتفاق
فرنسي بريطاني خلال قمه ثنائيه جامعه
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون برئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريش سوناك
اوضح ان الهدف ليس مواصله التعامل مع
المشكله بل حلها نهائيا ومن جهه اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون ضروره اشراك
الدول الاوروبيه المعنيه باللاجئين والدول
التي تمشط فيها شبكات الاتجار بالبشر
لمواجهه هذه الظاهره على حديث تعبيره
اتفقنا في الرابعه عشره من نوفمبر الماضي
على اطار ثنائي طموح لمواصله لمحاربه
الهجره غير النظاميه وقررنا اليوم
المواصله في هذا الاتجاه وبطريقه عمليه
وملموسه مدركين المسؤوليه المشتركه كما
قررنا تعزيز تنسيق انشطتنا ومبادرتنا مع
اشراك الدول الاوروبيه المعنيه بعبور
ومرور المهاجرين غير النظاميين ومع
البلدان التي تشهد التجارا بالبشر واتفقنا
على ضروره رفع قدراتنا للتدخل والمراقبه
من جهته اعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
تاسيس مركز احتجاز جديد في شمال فرنسا
لطالب اللجوء
ابحثيا مع الرئيس الفرنسي في باريس ان
هناك مركز قياده جديده يجمع 500 ضابط
اضافي للقيام بدوريات مشتركه على الشواطئ
الفرنسيه
ومركز قياده جديده يجمع فرقنا لاول مره في
مكان واحد و500 ضابط جديد اضافي يقومون
بدوريات في الشواطئ الفرنسيه
نحاول ان نفهم الان ابرز ما ورد في بنود
الاتفاق الجديد بين بريطانيا وفرنسا وفق
بيان صادر عن رئاسه الحكومه البريطانيه ما
الذي تم الاتفاق عليه ليله تم الاتفاق على
ان تساهم بريطانيا بخمسمائه
مليون دولار على مدى ثلاث سنوات للمساعده
في تكاليف وقف تدفق المهاجرين كذلك ستساعد
بريطانيا في تمويل مركز احتجاز جديد في
فرنسا وستدعم جهود باريس لزياده سعه
الاحتجاز ستشمل الحزمه الجديده ايضا انشاء
وحده امنيه فرنسيه دائمه للتعامل مع
القوارب الصغيره اضافه الى وحده مخصصه
للتعامل معابر القوارب الصغيره لنشر
مسيرات واعتماد تكنولوجيا المراقبه
بالطائرات